happy birthday it's your day to enjoy
however you want with lots of gifts and
sweets and look a little friend is here
to help you celebrate it's the birthday
monkey and he has a song to sing
dating back to the 1940s
scp-983 is one of the most harmless
looking objects in the scp foundation's
possession it's an old-fashioned
mechanical monkey a common wind-up toy
from the old days it's dressed in a
sharp little vest and holds a tiny bell
and striking rod for making music it
seems to be a simple toy the kind that
would annoy a tired parent as it plays
its little tune over and over but
nothing more but this is no ordinary
wind-up toy
scp-983 is capable of sounds and even
speech that doesn't seem to match up
with its design and an investigation
reveals it doesn't have any signs as to
how it was constructed no screws seams
or markings that would be common on a
toy and no voice box or other mechanical
feature that would allow for speech but
despite these oddities it seems to be a
normal toy that can be handled safely
and played with on every day but one
that is because
scp-983 has a second purpose and on one
special day it has a gift for its
handler it can be a gift of joy or a
gift of terror nicknamed the birthday
monkey
scp-983 activates when it is handled by
someone within the 24-hour period of
their birthday it seems to be able to
tell when this period of time happens
automatically and as soon as it becomes
aware a series of surprises begin to
surface for the lucky or unlucky handler
it starts with a little leap as soon as
scp-983 becomes aware of the birthday
boy or girl it'll do a charming little
backflip it'll then lift its bell and
start singing the same song a ringa ding
ding it's your birthday
to this day the foundation has not been
able to figure out exactly where this
voice comes from and it follows this by
ringing its bow the tone of the bell
varies widely in ways that the
instruments should not be able to create
ranging from low tones to painfully high
pitched tones and that's where the
horror begins the birthday monkey
doesn't just want to sing a song it
wants to play a game the song will
repeat every three to four seconds
marked by rings of the bell and for
every ring of the bell the birthday boy
or girl will age a year
continuing until they die of old age or
win the game but how does one win the
game before it's too late no one is sure
but studies of this strange toy in
action indicate that it involves singing
along and timing it correctly it's
probably a little hard to do that while
aging to death in seconds but no one
said scps play fair but in the event
that someone actually does manage to
survive the birthday monkeys game it has
a prize for them when the sing-along is
complete
scp-983 will let out an enthusiastic
shout of birthday ring its bell and drop
a single gum drop from its bell but
which gumdrop depends on just how well
the birthday victim did a perfect
sing-along will result in a clear candy
that seems to glow if it's a little less
than perfect the candy won't glow but
it'll work the same and both candies
have a very valuable property when eaten
the candy will immediately reverse any
age lost during the game but does the
perfect score give another prize studies
of the rare glowing candy led the
foundation to believe that it may also
provide a bonus effect making the person
who eats it younger and giving them a
longer lifespan or better health but
this is largely guesswork because the
candy is produced so rarely and the
effects would only become clear after
years or decades of study but not all
candies are to be eaten many candies of
different appearance and quality have
been produced all can be eaten safely
except the black ones which represent a
failed sing-along the effects of this
candy were discovered the hard way
because the first time
scp-983 was activated it was activated
in the wild before the foundation had
secured it and everyone knows that an
scp in the wild can be a terrible thing
it was at a local flea market when the
buyer noticed the sharp dressed little
monkey the buyer having a friend who
loved monkeys thought this would be a
perfect gift the seller was not as
enthusiastic and warned the buyer that
it shouldn't be handled or even seen by
anyone on their birthday but even the
seller didn't really believe this saying
that it might have just been an old
legend that had been passed down for
years it didn't dissuade the buyer and
off the monkey went to its new home
scp-983 was activated at an office party
where the monkey was presented as a gift
the guest of honor loved it at first
until it started singing the staff
noticed that as the monkey kept singing
their co-worker became more and more
upset the monkey kept singing and he
started to search for a way to turn it
off but there was no button or any other
way to deactivate it and that's when the
co-workers noticed something disturbing
the honoree seemed to be getting weaker
and weaker and there were even streaks
of grey appearing in his hair his skin
was getting more wrinkled and weathered
soon his hair was entirely gray and he
simply returned the monkey to where it
was as it continued to sing he seemed to
give up begged for someone to turn it
off and waited to expire by the time the
foundation arrived on the scene it was
already too late there was nothing left
of the birthday boy but a desiccated
skeletal corpse the monkey had been able
to sing at least 30 more verses and no
one had truly understood what was going
on they reacted with confusion and
inaction unable to contain the monkey's
dangerous game even the foundation
didn't understand
scp-983 at first so they let the object
continue singing until the body degraded
into a simple skeleton that's when the
monkey exclaimed its finishing phrase
and released a single black gumdrop
while no one ate the gumdrop the
foundation observed that it seemed to
hypnotize people around it as if it was
compelling them to do something what is
lurking within the black gumdrops and do
they want to be consumed the birthday
monkey was taken into scp custody and it
became clear that it was harmless to
everyone for 364 days of the year the
foundation wanted to understand more
about this odd toy so they fell back on
their best resource for testing d-class
personnel who got the chance to show off
their singing skills with much higher
stakes than your average round of
karaoke most of the tests were routine
with controlled activation showing how
to deactivate the monkey or providing
up-close studies of its devastating
effects but one test hinted that this
specimen could be more dangerous than
thought few people volunteer for testing
duty at the scp foundation but that
wasn't the case for one now classified
subject her birthday was approaching and
she surprisingly volunteered for the
test that could only be done on your
birthday she had an oddly upbeat
attitude and seemed oddly excited about
her birthday the test was approved and
she was given limited information she
was given the monkey as a wrapped gift
told it would sing and encouraged to
sing along for a video but her reaction
indicated she might know more than
expected as soon as the gift was
unwrapped the scp began singing after
missing the first verse the subject
picked up the words and started to sing
along not just competently but perfectly
and enthusiastically soon enough she
started aging rapidly but didn't seem
distressed by this at all she maintained
her high level of enthusiasm even as the
monkey sang for over 40 verses and aged
her over 40 years she seemed unaware of
these drastic changes and never missed a
beat of the song until the monkey issued
its finishing exclamation and now
it was time for her prize the gumdrop
that fell from the bell was a new one
completely white and almost shockingly
bright it glowed and the subject was
immediately enchanted by it even the
attending scientists and staff couldn't
help but comment on how impressive it
was the subject was allowed to consume
it to see its effects and was monitored
for an hour afterward when nothing
unusual happened besides the reversal of
the aging the subject was excused to
return to her quarters and that's when
things took a shocking turn in an effect
never seen before the subject suddenly
exploded with a brilliant burst of white
light whatever this light was it was
strong enough to knock out all the
cameras in the vicinity everyone in
their presence was temporarily blinded
with it taking five minutes for their
eyesight to return no long-term ill
effects were shown but the staff that
entered the room after the blast noticed
that the odd glow remained in the room
and that wasn't the only odd thing the
test subject was nowhere to be found and
has never been seen again the foundation
is on high alert for this test subject
but she seems to be staying below the
radar if she's even human at all anymore
while there is no physical sign of her
the foundation has observed odd patterns
of electromagnetic activity in the area
and is following reports of light
fixtures needing to be replaced it was
clear that
scp-983 was much more unpredictable than
expected while still classified as safe
the foundation is keeping scp-983 under
tighter lock and key these days all
technicians who handle it are carefully
vetted to ensure that they are nowhere
near their birthday in case of
accidental exposure the foundation has
prepared emergency kits with detailed
instructions for how to complete the
birthday monkey's deadly sing-along game
but as with all things the foundation is
prepared for anything in the event of a
failure the remains will be disposed of
by vetted staff any candies produced are
to be taken into custody by the
foundation and studied for unusual
properties but are not to be consumed
without full containment procedures and
approval from senior staff the only
exception is d-class testing but even in
those cases one rule remains intact no
one is ever to consume the black candies
and caution is encouraged around the
birthday monkey lest you wind up in a
sing-along for your life for more on an
ordinary object with unique properties
check out
scp-978 desire camera or watch scp-342 a
ticket to ride for another particularly
tricky trap